und dann hat die oecd diese woche mal
ganz offiziell deutschlands
rentenpolitik verrissen aber wie freunde
prädikat ich zitiere völlig unzureichend
hartes aber leider gerechtes experten
urteilt denn unserem land droht in der
tat eine art doppelherz entfahren das
ist so und als antwort auf drohende
altersarmut will die union jetzt
ernsthaft die klinisch tote
riester-rente wiederbeleben
obwohl alle experten sagen die
riester-rente stimmt schon aber gibt es
denn gar keine positive nachricht in
sachen rieste schade schade
ja ich sage es nochmal riester ist tot
unter anderem weil die versicherer da
viel zu hohe gebühren abgreifen
deutschland braucht eine echte
rentenreform und ich klein klein
schon ab dem jahr 2025 kann die groko
nicht mehr erklären wie die
beitragsfinanzierte rente funktionieren
soll
2025 ich habe nachgerechnet dass es in
sechs jahren quasi ist übermorgen
was heißt das müssen wir alle beide viel
länger arbeiten was soll man jetzt
machen was können sie aus denen raten
die ihm jetzt kein geld haben für
private vorsorge also tatsächlich muss
man denen raten erstmal darauf zu achten
dass sie möglichst mehr verdienen ach so
ach so wussten sie dass mehr verdienen
hilft gegen armut guck mal an
übrigens hat der mann da gerade völlig
recht in deutschland wird immer noch zu
wenig verdient wenn wir zum beispiel
einen mindestlohn von über 12 euro
hätten bräuchten wir gar keine
grundrente natürlich ist das mit der
rente kompliziert gebe ich gerne zu man
spricht ja nicht umsonst von der
quadratur des kreises ist das ist fakt
ist aber vom gewaltigen
produktivitätswachstum der letzten jahre
in deutschland ist zu wenig angekommen
bei arbeitnehmern es recht bei den
niedriglöhnern klar den meisten rentner
von heute geht es noch ganz gut die
die holy erbeutet neben 20 cent oder
sogar ausgedehnt was tina hier irgendwo
mal findet andy wenn du dir das mal so
ein kux das ist sogar comics ist du hast
du bist du junge leute in rente gehen
ist hamburg längst überflutet meine
meinung ich komme ich da ich muss mich
entschuldigen
wenn überhaupt kein mitleid applaus
bitte wenn überhaupt hat man doch eine
groko um große generationen themen große
themen wie die rente anzupacken
aber der groko kalender endet
anscheinend 2025 andererseits so what
freunde in sechs jahren wackelt die
rente aber kein grund zum trübsalblasen
wir feiern die große konkurrenten
abrissparty jetzt noch alles verjubeln
saufen kiffen kurzen bis der flieger
kommt und dazu die größten hits der
dreißiger vierziger und fünfziger und
das beste von heute die großen
abrissparty wir machen durch bis 2025
und busfahrer freunde
[Applaus]
hier hat alles rauslassen und da es in
der alten krankenkasse so ich behaupte
wenn deutschland von seinen nachbarn
lernen würde könnten wir die kommende
altersarmut noch aufhalten in österreich
zahlen fast alle berufstätigen in die
gesetzliche rente ein
seit 2005 auch neue beamte der
arbeitgeberanteil ist da höher als der
arbeitnehmeranteil und so kriegt der
durchschnittliche rentner in der
alpen-republik jetzt kommt 50 prozent
mehr als wir ja sogar der ur
österreicher erzielt
haben archäologen jetzt festgestellt
beim alter voll reichwein damen und
herren ja und es kommt noch schlimmer in
den niederlanden in den niederlanden
kriegt jeder der 50 jahre im land lebt
schon mal eine grundrente von 1200 euro
und es gibt eine verpflichtende
betriebsrenten an der sich arbeitgeber
und arbeitnehmer paritätisch beteiligen
die niederländer haben eine doppelt so
hohe rente wie die deutschen
aber ich könnte den total selbstständige
berufspolitiker und beamte müssen hier
endlich auch in die rentenkasse
einzahlen
aber da traut sie natürlich keine
regierung ran weil die chips haben wie
vor wem sie wohl offensichtlich vergisst
in mir ich lach mich schlapp über die
hammer dies der eine clown mit dem sich
keiner anlegt ist der gottverdammte
deutsche beamtenbund unser rentenniveau
sinkt aber niemand kürzt ihre pension
vorschlag wie wäre es denn wenn beamte
auch in die rentenkasse einzahlen so wie
alle anderen
überall gelungen gesetze also wirklich
jetzt die machen gesetze rund ein
viertel der abgeordneten sind beamte der
deutsche beamtenbund härter als die
schöne maria
[Musik]
ich weiß genau was wir ja unsere beamten
verdienen ihre pension staatsdiener
sollen gut versorgt sein tatsache ist
aber ein durchschnittlicher deutscher
rentner müsst du 120 jahre lang arbeiten
um auf die durchschnittspension eines
deutsche waffen zu kommen wirklich
wir brauchen eine echte rentenreform ich
sage es nochmal beispiel schweden die
haben einen sogenannten staatsfonds
derzeit man zweieinhalb prozent seines
gehalts 1
und der wird gemanagt von nur 27
mitarbeitern für ganz schweden bei
verwaltungsgebühren von gerade mal 0,1
prozent falls die groko das nachbauen
will hier die entsprechende anleitung
warum haben wir so was nicht in
deutschland weil dann keiner mehr
lebensversicherung oder riester verträge
abschließt kann man der abend branche
nicht antun
wann kommen die großen renten dem muss
der jungen menschen wann fangen die an
sich aufzuregen oder haben sie schon
alle hoffnung fahren lassen nach all den
unbezahlten praktika hier beim zdf
arbeitet genau eine junge frau es ist
unsere netz reporterin larissa hallo
hallo
[Applaus]
und ich bin es reportern ja genau was
machen sie sich den sorgen wegen der
rente natürlich herr oliver viele sind
da leider sehr sorglos sag ich war so
aber ich bin jemand der sich bezüglich
gedanken macht gerade über den die
chromatische entwicklung ja ja dann sehe
es nicht gut wirklich und bitte nicht
falsch verstehen ich liebe alte leute
wirkliche schwöre weil einige waren ja
früher auch mal menschen ist ja das
dürfen sie nie vergessen
sie stammen aus einer ganz anderen zeit
ohne ängste und tecdoc die arme sie
hatten nur facebook ja aber trotzdem
wissen sie eigentlich was auf unser land
zukommt das hier ja alle diese hier
sehen wollen mein geld
ja herr oliver und wir reden hier von
fakten die tatsachen sind also hier
steht zum beispiel zwei deutsche die
arbeiten führten heute ein rentner durch
ganz ehrlich ich würde das eher sogar
macht und wo mit dem ganzen herzen
aber ich weiß überhaupt nicht nur ein
paar wohnt wir stehen ist eine adresse
wie soll ich ihn der bitte füttern das
system ist krank
absolut und ihre eigene altersvorsorge
drei worte private vorsorge ja
warum machen die menschen mit ja
ja also ich betreibe ja phasenweise
tendenziell ständig private vorsorge
heute zum beispiel heute ist das
schönste tag des jahres
black friday ja ja das ganze ist voll
mit schnäppchen winter ja zum beispiel
in die hand gelegt was bekommen diese
wunderhübschen alltagstauglichen edlen
schuh von 100 euro oliver auf 80
schulter gesetzt das heißt ich habe
durch diesen kauf 20 euro verdient
ja das ist bares geld das ist schätzt
mehr heime für wenn ich mal alt bin ja
und dafür könnte ich mir dann später als
ein oma was kaufen was weiß ich was alte
leute mögen keine ahnung vielleicht ein
baum suppe oder ein hohn
ok ja da sind ja schöne ansätze dabei
larissa und habe aber natürlich können
wir die kontinuierliche verwesung des
landes noch stoppen
ja das ist sehr einfach die frage ist
was machen den retter den ganzen tag
genau sie fahren e bike also den bikes
waren die rentner ja
und deswegen man sehr einleuchtende idee
wenn wir heute endlich alle fahrer käme
verbieten ist meine rennt morgen sicher
verstehe
ich fasse zusammen dass behörde schuhe
kaufen und fahrradhelme verbieten gegen
altersarmut dann würde ich sagen er ist
das beste kommt noch eine todsichere
idee für ihre altersvorsorge warte ich
schwöre viele müssen das nicht aber es
gibt in dresden schloss dagegen eher so
you drin
ja ja und da kann man eins rein gehen da
ist an der seite entfernt hat das musst
du auch wirklich geschritten ist ein
guter freund von einem freund von mir
den kursen von sind schwager ja der hat
mit seinen freunden damit gerade für
sein alter vorgesorgt oliver schaut das
hatte man mit geprägt konsumo de absolut
unseren schlägt hierfür weitere heute
schon videos und klickt im moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]